I'm assuming you've gotten a lot of good
advice over your career but I'm curious
what is the worst advice you've ever
received
advice I ever received
[Music]
receipt that's a toughie I think people
are afraid to give me bad advice
okay
yeah yeah that's good I'll come back and
bite you man I'll make your favorite
what kind of advice was that not to say
it that I don't make bad decisions
um but you make them I make them exactly
so you can own that I own it and I own
up I love that bad decision all right
you have an archive in your house where
you keep your rewards you know but there
was one thing that your son gravitated
towards can you please tell me I've been
dying to know what is it none of my
awards were out
and my son just said he's like Mom where
are all your awards they're in the
archives there and which is a small room
in the basement
he goes well
can't we just at least put the Grammys
up so we we've got the grommets we put
them on the Shelf he's so inspiring he's
like like don't do anyone to see them
don't you aren't you proud of these
these are like you've earned these and
um so it was really cute but uh yeah so
we have quit started putting more of my
Awards out you have Harry Styles Taylor
Swift they're all your fans is he aware
of like how big his mom is are you just
like Mom I need dinner come on
oh no no no he sees me as mom my mom all
the way
[Music]
chief he knows what I represent
um in my career
does not see me as that that don't
impress me much last time we talked to
you actually about Asia d uh you told us
that he wanted to get into audio
engineering I don't know if that's still
the the plan would you ever let him work
with you on your music oh he
on now and to music and that is his
passion he lives he sprays it one of his
songs is on my current drama on the
queen of Me album wow I didn't tell him
he was on it until it was already done
wow too high but yeah he's very talented
we don't work together per se really
loves his independence he does his own
thing he listens to a lot of music that
I would never have discovered without
him I'm not you know we're just in
different places musically but which is
why I chose this song because it really
brought me out of my own comfort zone my
own phrasing Zone my own melodic Zone
and it was a great experience to do that